do you guys know a year and a half ago  what they were bashing uh Buffett for  Warren Buffett sitting on 125 billion  dollars of cash with Berkshire Hathaway  we feel Warren buff has lost his ways  you know he is no longer the same Warren  Buffett he once used to be the last  seven years he's been you're losing to  SMP you are better off to put the money  in the S P 500 or Bitcoin or ethereum  rather than putting the money with  Berkshire Hathaway  how many guys would love to have 125  billion dollars of cash today  what do you think he's about to buy  he's going shopping and guess what he's  buying the next three six 12 months  companies on Flipping sale  and the next thing you know boom next  level